avant de partir en voyage
il faut vérifier votre taux at elle
besoin d'un recevait l'aj la route
secours et elle comme il faut oui ne
partez jamais avec une automobile en
mauvais état allez jeter un coup d'oeil
aux moteurs et rappelez vous les points
les plus importants du bon
fonctionnement
vous devez bien sûr vérifier le niveau
d'huile indispensable pour le moteur
vous devez vérifier le niveau d'eau du
radiateur 6,7 un refroidissement à eau
bien sur l'eau du lave glace
la route sera peut-être poussiéreuse
qu'est-ce que j'oublie l'eau distillée
dans la batterie et enfin et peut-être
surtout le niveau du liquide de freinage
une fois rendu à son poste de pilotage
le conducteur doit vérifier c'est la
glace ses essuie-glaces ses phares code
veilleuse ses clignotants et puis aussi
bien sûr
l'avertisseur sonore non non non
monsieur l'agent je m'impatiente part je
tourne pour la télévision
enfin si vous faites un voyage important
si vous prenez la route
vous prenez des risques pourquoi ne pas
confier votre voiture à l'un des centres
de sécurité automobile
ils sont nombreux en france et croyez
moi des gens compétents vous donneront
un avis sérieux